(electronic music)
(cheering)
- Street Meat!
- Squat Sauce!
- Street Meat, time to
become a gentleman once more.
- To what do I owe the honor?
- Well it's our annual time to be together
and watch the game of football.
- Oh what a delight.
(cheering)
- Gettin back to basics,
dude, with a little football.
Let's play some actual sports that require
actual athleticism.
- Yeah, dude, basketball, (blowing)
Golf?
- Boring.
- I got ESPN3, and I've
been watching like sports
from countries around the world.
And they're just superior, you know?
- Yeah, what's your
favorite foreign sport?
- Oh far and away it's gazelle charging.
- Gazelle charging?
- Yeah, no it's this East African sport
where a man places a whole
bloody lion's head on his chest,
and whoever scares the gazelle the most,
you know, that's the winner.
- I was in Indonesia a few years ago,
they had pot fights.
- Pot fights?
- Pot fights, as best I could
tell, it was like boxing,
with big pots.
(bell ringing)
- That's not at all like boxing.
- [Squat Sauce] Dude.
- [Street Meat] So they
beat each other with like,
spaghetti pots?
- Yeah, a bunch.
- That sounds like fucking murder.
- [Squat Sauce] They go
"Pot!
"Pot!"
- [Street Meat] They speak English?
- They speak the word pot a lot.
- Have you ever seen wounding before?
- Wounding?
- Yeah, wounding?
- I've seen people get wounded?
- Wounding is this great sport
with like sharpened sticks,
it's a Canadian sport.
- See those motherfuckers smile a bunch,
then all of a sudden,
- Yeah.
- they bring out the pointy sticks.
- [Street Meat] They
would just take sticks
and fucking sharpen them.
They'd smear mud in their eyes
so their vision was blurred
and then you just stab and
as soon as you get blood
on your stick your team wins.
- You ever see people head wrestle?
- I don't think that's a thing.
- With head wrestling, there's
so many different tactics
that people use.
Like there's Hammerhead,
which you just supposed to hit
people until they fall over.
Then there's the Mountain,
and you just push and
push and push and push
until you eventually
like, erode your enemy.
- My thing is, any rare sport.
Cause I think of soccer as a rare sport.
- [Squat Sauce] Well there's
a whole other element to it
that we don't get here in America.
- Dude, fucking, American
sports can suck my ballsack.
- Yeah.
- They can.
They have a cordial invitation
to taste the savory flavors
of my ballsack.
- Sha bam!
Gooooooooal!
- Stop!
- Gooooooooal!
- Stop it!
- Now I'm impressed.
- Okay, thank you.
- It became impressive.
- That's all I wanted.
- The point wasn't enough.
(whistle blowing)
- Yeah, bro, what are you up to later?
- I'm going to a Chargers' game.
- Yeah!
- Sweet!
(electronic music)